believing that the world is progressive
it's moving forward helps me continue
when I want to give up
[Music]
ryan mathews have been 17 at the time
that he got arrested and charged with
first-degree murder and face the death
penalty
on Mother's Day we were sitting there in
court with Ryan's mum when the jury
returned the verdict of death on her
child I felt like I'd failed in the one
task that I've been given it felt like
the most hopeless moment after Ryan was
convicted of murder and sentenced to
death
that's when we actually started to work
on his case Ryan spent five years on
death row
this one here is Ryan when he was
released from death row in 2004 the
beauty of the story from me was that in
2008 his sister got married and asked me
to come and be her bridesmaids at her
wedding and Ryan was the
and so we got to walk down the aisle of
the church the man that I first met or
the boy that I'd first met when he was
census of death and I got to walk down
the aisle of the church and his sister's
wedding I can tell you the story in a
couple of minutes but that whole thing
took nine years 1999 to 2008 to the
wedding and there were so many points in
that that I wanted to give up and the
thing that motivated me back was always
being in touch with Ryan and his family
and so the people in all of this are the
things that bring me back when I want to
give up one of the most important things
I've learnt and this has continued over
my life is choose your role models
carefully
affects the office it was before there
was email in New Orleans and sent my CV
which had probably nothing on it and
said who want to come work with globe
SAP and Smith and then was really
surprised that no one got back to me and
and I think my parents said well maybe
you should phone and I like because that
felt uncomfortable I was young I guess
they didn't feel confident but I did
phone up and my CV had been put on the
top of some filing cabinet somewhere and
the office manager dug it out and I said
yeah sure Turner why don't we turn off
in the summer
choosing my role model carefully was
really important I could become the kind
of lawyer that I always wanted to be by
learning from him
I've always been this small person
taking on the big government and that
can often be a really scary thing but
the reason why we have the story of
David and Goliath is that the small guy
can make the change so one of the things
that has always really helped me is
quotes or poems that inspire me and
every day there'll be something that
will motivate me or focus me and it just
makes me feel connected to other
people's struggles one of the ones that
we always use in our work with the young
people is a Martin Luther King quote the
arc of history is long but it bends
towards justice
you